In this session we're going to take a look at shadows. This is a little
environment i built and it's being lit by a directional light. When doing
trivial graphics rendering, which I'm doing here, shadowing is typically not
supported. For instance we can see that light leaks in under the little roof in
the back of the scene. so let's lay a little shadowing. Now we can see that the
scene is being properly shadowed. Parts of the environment that were previously
incorrectly lit are now dark. This happens because we are now disabling light
if there is something between the light source and the geometry. By rotating
the light, we can also place the shadow where we want it. But there is still
something wrong with the shadows. View live shadows are typically not as sharp
as what we see here. Now we have enabled soft shadows. This looks much more
realistic. Perfectly sharp shadows come from assuming the light sources
infinite this small. In real life, light sources have size. And by taking it in
consideration, we get a soft shadow border. This shadow border separates the
shadow into two parts. We call the completely shadowed area the umbra. And the
soft part with the gradient the penumbra. The penumbra happens in regions of
the surface where the light source is being partially occluded. Also note how
the penumbra has been small when the lit point is close to the occluder, and
large when it's farther away. This wraps up the part about shadowing. Thanks
for your attention